puis ton père
bush m
aum
tu as gagné
je suis
à gagner je suis comme un poids
je suis tombé
bakou
et a fait aussi une magnifique tête pour
à 9,7 au monde le sexe de son futur bébé
c'est ce qu'on appelle une baby shower
eh bien nous ce soir on va faire ce
qu'on appelle une mamie chômage mais
pour qui je veux explique isabelle
isabelle va sur quatre dans une cabine
de doute maths je vais tenter les
questions sur les bébés donc alors si tu
est fin prêt à devenir papa
ok tu réponds bien tout va bien si tu te
trompes la douche se mettra en route
alors de l'eau coulera sur isabelle
suant sang français combien n'assiste
pas à la naissance de l'europe et tout
pour tout caler doukkali nous on avait
dit combien toi maladie 20-20 elle à
10,55 la bonne réponse est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore commun qui apporte en plus mais
il donne des airs il donne des détails
les tailles des détails mon frère on
attend la tête de ma mère je croyais
qu'ils m'aident à oui alors oui vous
dire un truc je voulais dire un truc
il appelle un taxi j'ai oublié harkis
dessinée qui a construit quel architecte
de la pyramide du louvre parce que ces
rapports nabila je crois que c'est bing
et céline ans et plus et c'est payet bon
l'attend depuis de nombreuses semaines
on la quitte jacky depuis très très
longtemps et c'est vrai pour confirmer
inès in et screg est avec moctar
on va mettre la musique de dirty dancing
attention tu vas faire le porte et fat
en soit ça 3 2 ap
dans l'hérault date à date
attendez quoi donc y'a plus de respect
c'est kevin donc c'est le mec d'inès la
cabine
c'est ce soir que je te mets des
paillettes dans ta vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu un congrès du genre
on va faire la meilleure offre et il m'a
inspiré pour créer un jeu dans lequel on
va s'affronter tous les deux dans
l'écran vont apparaître deux offres une
offre visible et une offre mystère ces
offres sont des défis on va devoir
relever tous les deux à toi de choisir
en premier si tu veux l'offre vizille où
l'offre mystère moi je ferais l'autre
quoi qu'il arrive à les jours ou à l'eau
sans l'autre alors moi donc je vais me
faire un corner de martin parr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je garde pour moi je viens combes et tu
avais aucune téléphone est en projet
ouais jonathan je suis désolé mais je
sais pas si t'es au courant tu l'as vu
mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et si je peux je pense à des collabos
des missions de tomber le chaman cyril
te parle
je n'attends merci vous allez et
franchement il est désolé c'est pas la
faute de julien voilà au nom de toute
l'équipe
sachez qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire d'agathe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si on parlait de la poitrine de
christine kelly qui passionne pas mal de
monde autour de la table on l'adoré
enfin surtout un d'ailleurs autour de la
table c'était comme regarder les images
vont le faire entrer que tim kelly qui
nous fasse un témoignage mais jamais
comme ça c'est trop beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on va passer
je suis ma série